[Musique]
une réunion au sommet puisqu'ils étaient
présents les deux ministres elisabeth
bornes au travail à l'espagne hier une
hache et pour l'industrie ainsi que le
président de la région xavier bertrand
nationaliser lusine c'est envisageable
ou pas tout est envisageable et amsted
tout est envisageable à partir du moment
où il ya une perspective la question
c'est pas de mettre de l'argent public à
fonds perdus si jamais l'état la région
et tout ça prenne des participations
dans bridgestone
il faut qu'elle soit extrêmement
conditionné oui il faut qu'on ait des
garanties des garanties fermes et si
tout ce qui nous anime aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir des avancées importantes ce qui
nous anime c'est que les salariés de
leur poule et un emploi dans un an dans
besoin dans trois ans je ne vais pas de
bridgetown pour nous il ya eu des pêches
et dire que la cessation d'activité là
les ministres nous disent que c'est même
l'un des grands pas de la provocation de
la direction donc la question c'est ce
qu'ils se foutent de nous ou pas réponse
dans quinze jours la scène se déroule en
pleine journée à bron à proximité de la
mairie
quelques heures plus tôt en début
d'après-midi un mariage dégénère avec
une série d'incivilités
ça concerne la plupart du temps certains
mariages qui sont marocains algériens ou
de jure qu'il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont
il faut pas je le vois à forbach
malheureusement quasiment chaque semaine
c'est insupportable pour tout le monde y
compris pour d'autres je précise tout de
suite marocains algériens et turcs qui
se comporte très bien et pas du tout
comme ça mais on a quand même peu de
chances de se tromper quand quant au
coach lorrain
mais voilà la noblesse bretonne
mais j'adore alors à la tirade raciste
de monsieur c'est non c'est pas raciste
je vous permet pas de le dire certains
médias voilà non c'est tout c'est votre
avant vous disent que vous laisse vous
voulez moi la femme et vous le dites est
ce qu'un professeur doit ressembler à ça
tatoués de la tête aux pieds elle
certains désapprouvent
apparemment pas l'éducation nationale
même ses yeux sont colorés par l'unchr
continue n'est pas dans un salon de
tatouage sylvain 35 ans est aussi
professeur remplaçant en essonne et un
peu angoissant et un peu angoissant faut
quand même se le dire non c'est pas
encore une fois tout en boîte sont pour
vous les bons et pour d'autres personnes
effectif mais est fait avec tous les
goûts sont dans la nature et et
personnellement je n'étais pas je n'ai
pas fait ça pour ça ce n'est pas pour
provoquer les réactions je vais ça pour
moi avant tout le sport spectacle à une
fonction mais le dit il le dit christian
prudhomme et des bas il ya 35 % de
chômeurs on va pas leur donner du boulot
on va leur faire regarder le tour de
france et leur fils et des goodies bon
et en attendant il reste il reste calé
devant leur télé à rêver à des exploits
de de type hyper dopé je pense que cette
personne n'a jamais regardé tour de
france qu'il qui n'a jamais pris un vélo
femmes 1
je sais pas je trouve ça d'une commande
d'un élitisme et du tamis prix de classe
absolument mépris de classe absolument
flamboyant parce qu'ils déclenchent
sébacées pas les petites phrases qui
déclenche en fait c'est juste que le cap
que qui est porté par les écologistes le
cac est choisi par un vent de france et
les français dans les grandes villes
mais en fait dans beaucoup de villes
moyennes aussi on n'en parle pas assez
dans le village est en fête
il est pour eux c'est un modèle qui
attaque complètement la logique
néolibérale
totalement produit utilise
d'exploitation de la terre et des
humains ouais et donc ça c'est la dèche
la meilleure défense c'est la date il un
article du sud ouest c'était dans la
lune jean lassalle se gare sur le
passage à niveau
c'est au regard de ce député vous avez
votre voiture qui a empêché de passer
quoi et vraiment jean lassalle s'excuse
il reconnaît auprès de nos confrères de
sud-ouest qui l'avait trouvé je cite une
place miraculeuse en arrivant je n'ai
pas mais alors pas du tout pensé au
train dit-il
il ya des moments le marché revient aux
noeuds j'avais l'habitude mais beaucoup
de gens s'y mettent et là qu'elles
avaient des troupeaux de brebis qui
passait devant de cette voie ferrée qui
était très sympa tant qu un très mauvais
moment